our first year of being global it's so
great to finally arrived in Tokyo Tokyo
is a blast but now it's time to go home
Brooklyn New York
check out the info you don't like to see
me when you see me see me i style hidden
up the weather get you feeling how it's
lights out why you wanna mad though cuz
all I do is cash out to my sauce in the
buildings with pink foam my name is Joe
Perry and I'm a trip to the club kinfolk
we are at kinfolk 94 wife Avenue hello
love this place the story is like a
restaurant with a small menu which is my
favorite thing it's got all these like
incredible jewels in it to bees they're
amazing bottle openers and there's must
be a thousand stories in this room you
guys are known for logos and graphics
and super cool clothes you do this on
the front that would be killer
we want to see what you're thinking for
this collection I'm excited about this
one
what's the fabric on this we went at the
end with a cotton this this is one of my
favorite pieces I would say this is
probably very challenging we tried to do
it in years past and they weren't able
to produce it we ever worked it out for
us to see if we can point you to make
this happen
that's a first for you you don't do a
scarf do you and Kim Phuc forte is to
translates the culture that way into
everything that we into would like to
use fashion as a canvas and like through
graphic and through little details
express what we about in closing that
allow truck always there the branding is
a very aggressive is that a graphic that
you would put on a t-shirt I mean the
whole menu on the t-shirt will be
amazing it would be amazing
right there's inspiration everywhere
how are you sir
this one here Butera growing up in in
France in the nineties New York was the
mecca for culture I will dream about
living in New York all my youth it feels
homey enough nice approved kinfoke
approves welcome to the neighborhood I
got my office in the back you also cut
here here in the weekend on your way up
let me know the branding in the graphic
that we created for this gap
collaboration it's American subculture
New York subculture from the 70s and
early 80s though whole wall is passing
through these streets it's just part of
a new New York fashion the way we're
doing it is so very niche thank God we
have a nightclub let me put it that way
we use nightlife as a vector for culture
people can go in for nightclub and have
a good time I like vodka
but music here the first kiss happen
here
god knows what I put in the bathroom
that's a different topic we always try
to bring the culture to those garments
and I catch it that way I'm stoked you
know I'm stalled why I just went through
the feeling this week everything looks
great can't wait to have a full simple
line and the lounge should be a good for
you in the roots to do routine then
we're shooting for GQ gap trifecta at
this point I love it